so now it's time to cover the building
blocks to use when doing data store
modeling they are kind entity and
property let's start with kind shall we
a kind is a name that defines a
particular structure for our conference
central application two different kinds
are for example profile and conference a
kind is similar to the concept of
classes in object-oriented programming
given a kind you can create many
entities of that kind so in this picture
we can see three entities one for the
profile kind and two for the conference
kind and as you can see entities are
very similar to the concept of objects
in object-oriented programming and each
entity holds a set of properties which
are highlighted by the red sections in
this picture and by now you can see that
properties are very similar to the
concept of fields members or attributes
in object-oriented programming in fact
you can also find similarities with
relational database modeling let's look
at a table that summarizes these things
so a kind in that Benjen data store can
be thought of as a class in
object-oriented programming and as a
table in relational database modeling
and an entity in App Engine datastore
can be thought of as an object in
object-oriented programming or as a row
in relational database modeling and
finally a property in datastore can be
thought of as a field or attribute in
object-oriented programming and as a
column in relational database modeling
but this is on a very high level since
there are many things that differ in
data stored compared to the other
technologies you shouldn't consider
these as direct analogies it could help
you out in the beginning but as we dig
deeper into how data store works you
will start to see more and more
differences